الان ينضم الينا من رام الله الخبير في
الشؤون الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه اللواء
الركن المتقاعد واصف عريقات اهلا بك معنا
سيد واصف اذا في الوقت الذي يعلن فيه
المسؤولون الاسرائيليون بان شمال القطاع
بات تحت يطره ناريه كامله من جانب قواته
ولكن نتابع هذه الاشتباكات المتواصله
تحديدا في جباليا ولازالت المقاومه هناك
تبدي استع دا ل المقاومه وبالتالي كيف
تفسر ما
يجري يعني اولا في فرق ما بين السيطره
الناريه والسيطره البشريه السيطره الناريه
يستطيع الجيش الاسرائيلي ومنذ اليوم الاول
يعني عنده طائرات هذه تسمى سيطره ناريه
عنده دبابات تسيطر ناريا عنده مدفعيه
تسيطر ناريا الاساس هو السيطره البشريه
بمعنى ان تنتهي السيطره الناريه يعني ان
تتوقف الطائره عن القصف يتوقف المدفع عن
القصف تتوقف الدبابه عن التقدم على الارض
ويترجل الجندي الاسرائيلي ويطهر المنطقه
من المقاومه ويسيطر عليها لذلك هو يتلاعب
بالالفاظ حينما نسمع انه يقول سيطره ناريه
اليوم بعد 78 يوم هذا يعني بالتاكيد ضعف
اسرائيلي ضعف للجيش الاسرائيلي وخاصه في
المناطق الاولى التي تم تجاوزها في
الساعات الاولى من الحرب البريه وهناك خلط
حقيقه الان يعني وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه تبث معلومات امنيه
واستقبال يعني يعني خطط عسكريه لا اساس
ولا علاقه لها بارض الواقع ام هم يريدون
هم يريدون تهيئه الراي العام في داخل
اسرائيل ولمن يتابع اسرائيل من الحلفاء
يهيئون لمراحل لا علاقه لها بمراحل الحرب
البريه مراحل الح الحرب البريه لم تكتمل
ما طبيعه هذه المراحل التي يحاولون الوصول
اليها او تهيئه الراي العام الاسرائيلي
اليها مراحل انهاء العمليه هناك فرق بين
مراحل تنفيذ العمليه وهناك مراحل انهاء
العمليه هناك خلط الان عند الجيش
الاسرائيلي وعند القياده الاسرائيليه وهذا
الخلط انا بتقديري متعمد هو من اجل الوعي
المعركه الان معركه الوعي يريدون بث وعي
عند الجمهور الاسرائيلي وليس عندنا عندنا
الوعي واضح ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه هي
التي تحقق الانجاز على الارض الوعي
الاسرائيلي يريد ان يستعيد ما كان قبل 17
وهذا ما لا يمكن لانه مرحله تنفيذ العمليه
هي اربعه تقدم تمدد تطويق تطهير هذا لم
يحدث حتى الان حدث ثلاث مراحل المرحله
الرا الرابعه لم تحدث حتى الان بمعنى
التطيير بمعنى السيطره لا يمكن الحديث عن
سيطره حتى سيطره ناريه لا يمكن الحديث
عنها ما دام هناك بندقيه وما دام هناك
مقاومه يقاتل اذا هم يخلطون بين مرح مراحل
تنفيذ العمليه ومراحل انهاء العمليه نعم
الخلط بينهما حينما يقول تقليص القوات هذا
يعني مراحل انهاء العمليه طيب انت بدك
تقلص قواتك وانت ما انهيت عمليتك ما نفذت
اهدافك وهنا اسالك سيد وا كيف تفسر تقليل
اعداد جنود الاح
واعاده هذه الترتيبات لدى قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه في غزه ومنها طبعا
سحب لواء جولاني او فرقه من لواء جولاني
اختي غ اخت غنوه يعني هم فشلوا في تحقيق
الاهداف واستمرارهم يعني مزيد من الخسائر
في الارواح البشريه والمعدات القتاليه
وكما جرى مع لواء المظليين بالشمال ومع
لواء الجولاني في في الشمال ايضا في منطقه
الشجاعيه هذا س سينس سحب على بقيه القوات
فلذلك هم يحاولون ال الايحاء بانهم يزجون
بمزيد من القوات وفي نفس الوقت تحت هذا
الغطاء يسحبون اعداد كبيره من القوات لانه
اصبح هناك ادراك عند القياده العسكريه
والسياسيه الاسرائيليه انه مهما طال امد
القتال لن يحققوا اهدافهم فبالتالي
يحاولون الان تهيئه الاجواء وخاصه الجبهه
الداخليه الاسرائيليه بهذه ال المراحل
التي يتحدثون عنها كيف نفهم حديث
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين عن تقسيم القطاع
الى ثلاثه مناطق منطقه نزوح منطقه
اشتباكات ومنطقه عمليات كبرى ماذا يعني
ذلك يعني هذه هذه مصطلحات جديده على على
المفهوم العسكري لم لم يسيطروا حتى الان
على بقعه واحده يعني اذا ما تحدثنا عن
اشتباكات في جباليا في بيت لاهيه في بيت
حنون هذه في مناطق مناطق حدوديه قريبه
يعني مناطق تسمى قشره قشره يعني ليست في
عمق قطاع غزه ولم يسيطروا عليها اذا كيف
سيتحدثون عن مناطق عزل كيف سيتحدثون عن
مناطق يسيطر عليها فبالتالي ما دام هناك
مقاومه ما دام هناك اشتباكات على الارض
انا بتقديري لا مجال لتنفيذ اي خطه
يتحدثون عنها كل ما كل ما يبث الان عبر
وسائل الاعلام وعبر الصحافه الاسرائيليه
هي معلومات امنيه واستخبارات صادره عن
الاجهزه الامنيه والاستخباري الاسرائيليه
وليس لها علاقه بارض الواقع ارض الواقع
تقول حيثما تواجد الجندي الاسرائيلي هناك
اشتباكات معه هناك اطلاق نار هناك قصف
مدفعيه هناك يعني حينما يتدخل الطيران في
الشمال طيب الطيران يتدخل في الشمال وهناك
جنود اسرائيليين هل هل يقوم الطيران
الاسرائيلي بقتل الجنود الاسرائيليين في
الشمال طيب الشمال له 78 يوم وهنا اسالك ل
نوصف الواقع اكثر بعد 78 يوما
برايك الى اي مدى تمكنت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من تقويض
مقدرات المقاومه بكل
فصائلها يعني بالتاكيد ما زالت يعني خسرت
المقاومه بالتاكيد يعني هذا القصف الذي
شمل كامل مساح قطاع غزه يعني المقاومه ما
هي جزء من المدنيين صحيح ولكن جسم
المقاومه الذي يقاتل الان يؤكد بان
المقاومه بخير وان المقاومه قادره على
الاستمرار كما يعني كما يقع خسائر في
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقع خسائر ايضا في
المقاومه لا ننكر ذلك يعني هناك حرب اباده
جماعيه ضد الفلسطينيين بشكل عام سواء كان
مدنيين او مقاومين والمقاومين موجودين
موجودين في مواقعهم ولكنهم يشتبكون ما
نشاهد حتى الان هناك هناك مقاومه باسله ما
زالت قويه قادره على على منع على منع
وتحريم منع وتحريم الجندي الاسرائيلي من
السيطره على الارض وهذا هذا يؤكد بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي الان يفكر في كيف يخرج
من مازق وليس كيف يستمر في قتاله لانه
الاستمرار في القتال مزيد من التهلكه
للجيش الاسرائيلي لاحظنا اليوم اشرطه
فيديو تبث في داخل اسرائيل كيف يتبول
الجنود الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه حين
ملاقاتهم للمقاتلين الفلسطينيين وهذه
الظاهره منتشره هناك ظواهر كثيره منتشره
تؤكد بان المعنويات عند الجنود
الاسرائيليين متدنيه بالحض ونحن نعلم ان
الجندي لا يقاتل بسلاحه بقدر ما يقاتل
بمعنويات المعنويات رغم كل الالم
الفلسطيني رغم كل الدماء الفلسطينيه رغم
الشهداء حجم الشهداء الفلسطينيين رغم
تدمير البنيه التحتيه في في قطاع غزه ولكن
المقاتل الفلسطيني ما زال يملك معنويات
وما زال يقاتل ببساله واعتقد انه لديه
الامكانيه ان يقاتل لمسافه طويله ولوقت
طويل سيد واصف تبعنا هذا الشارخ الحاصل
بين المؤسسه العسكريه الاسرائيليه وحكومه
نتنياهو بما يتعلق باتخاذ قرار الحرب
والاستمرار فيها ازاء هذه المعطيات هل
هناك ادراك واجماع اسرائيلي على ضروره وقف
هذه
الحرب يعني نتنياهو يريد اطاله امد القتال
صحيح لانه عارف انه انهاء القتال ليس
لصالحه وسيذهب الى الى القضاء والسجن ال
الوز وزير الحرب ورئيس هيئه الاركان
كلاهما ايضا يريد الثار والانتقام من ال
من المقاومه الفلسطينيه ومن الشعب
الفلسطيني هذا وارد ومعروف ولكن هناك ايضا
ليسوا هم فقط الجيش الاسرائيلي هناك
قيادات هناك ضباط هناك ضباط متقاعدين
يتحدثون يعني حينما حينما يتحدث اولمرت
وهو كان رئيس وزراء سابق ويقول يجب انهاء
القتال لماذا لانه توصل الى قناعه بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يخسر ولا يكسب ولا ولا
يتقدم لا يحقق انجازات على الارض هناك
كبار كبار القاده الاسرائيليين الذين
خاضوا معارك سابقه نسمع تحليلاتهم على
الفضائيات الكل يتحدث ان اسرائيل بعيده عن
الحسم اسرائيل بعيده عن الواقع
بعي يستخدمون يعني مصطلح السيف لم يقع على
رقبه المقاومه بمعنى انه فيش ضغوطات على
المقاومه حتى حتى تتنازل عن عن مواقفها
فبالتالي هم يمتدحون المقاومه وقدرات
المقاومه ومهارات الميدانيه عند المقاومين
يعني حينما نشاهد في الصوت والصوره كيف
يمتطي المقاوم بعد مرور 78 يوم الدبابه
والاليه ويقنط ويقتل كل من فيها كيف كيف
يرمي المقاوم الفلسطيني على الدبابه وهو
متحركه وهذا بالعلم العسكري من اصعب
الاهداف ان ترمي هدفا متحرك
لانه يحتاج الى الموائمه بين سرعتين سرعه
الدبابه وسرعه المقذوف وهذا ان دل على شيء
يدل على ان المقاومه بعد 78 يوم ما زال
يمتلك القدرات والمهارات والشجاعه والهدوء
يعني لاحظي في كل في في هذه الظروف الصعبه
يعني وقصف الطيران والاباده الجماعيه
وسياسه الارض المحروقه يخرج المقاتل من
تحت الانقاض وينتظر الدباب وهي هدف متحرك
هدف متحرك يحتاج
الى يستهدفها سيد واصف كيف تفسر ما يقوله
المسؤولون الاسرائيليون عن التركيز الان
على معركه خان يونس في الوقت الذي على ما
يبدو وفق المعطيات هو لم يحسم الامر في
شمال القطاع وفق ما
يقول اولا المعركه ليست معركه يعني قريه
او مدينه او موقع او نفق او قائد هذا هذا
ليس هدفا للجيش الاسرائيلي ولكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي يريد ان يغطي على ضعفه المعركه
معركه مقاومه المقاومه مجوده منتشره قدت
حماس متواجدون
في جنوب
القطاع حتى لو كانوا موجودين حتى لو لو
وجدهم حتى لو
اغتالهم يعني هي المقاومه متوقفه على
اشخاص المقاومه مقاومه موجوده ومنتشره
الجيش الاسرائيلي يريد ان يحقق هدف حينما
يتحدث عن ذلك لانه لا يريد هو رفع رفع من
اليوم الاول هدف القضاء على المقاومه اذا
المقاومه هدف بعيد المنال هو يحاول الان
التراجع لانه شعر بان هذا الهدف لا يمكن
تحقيقه لا
يمكن القياده القياده مثلها مثل المقاومين
حينما تكون في الميدان هي مشاريع شهاده
ولكن لا يعني يعني استشهاد قائد او قائدين
او ثلاثه لا يعني وقف القتال القتال سيبقى
مستمر والهدف الذي التي اعلنته اسرائيل
كونها غير قادره على تحقيقه فهي تحاول
التراجع عنه هي تريد مره ان تقول انفاق
وتريد مره ان تقول القائد سن السنوار
وتريد مره ان تقول الاسرى والرهائن هي لا
تعرف ماذا تريد لانه لا يوجد لديها
معلومات امنيه واستخبر حتى الان فبالتالي
هذه الاهداف ال الغير الغير معروفه للجنود
الاسرائيليين حتى الان هم يبحثون عنها
حقيقه فلذلك
يتخبطون
ويتشدقون باهداف عاليه السقف ولكن على ارض
الواقع لا علاقه لها بما يجري هناك
اشتباكات الان في كل مكان يعني نحن نلاحظ
اين تقصف المدافع اين تقصف الطائرات اين
يكون هناك اشتباكات قريبه ومباشره على هذا
الاساس نكون شكرا شكرا لك من رض العسكريه
الاسيه كيف تكون فاشله نعم الخبير في
الشؤون الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه اللواء
الركن المتقاعد واصف عريقات